Elon Musk owns Twitter uh he is not a
fan of diversity equity and inclusion I
want to start this off by showing you
two tweets from Elon he wrote this Dei
is just another word for racism shame on
anyone who uses it yes that's right and
that's in reference to a tweet by Bill
Amman which I suspect we'll talk a bit
more about Bill Amman throughout the
week but let's just move on to the next
tweet from Elon he wrote discrimination
on the basis of race which Dei does is
literally the definition of racism and
of course that is true there is no such
thing as Reverse Racism if you don't
like white people or you won't hire
white people uh in the name of Dei you
are a racist anyway those are two fairly
obvious statements that Elon Musk put
out there those are the ideas that this
country was founded on on equality and
not being racist that's how things used
to work but Mark cubin who owns the
Dallas Mavericks who has allowed all of
this nonsense into his corporate
institution uh he tweeted back at Elon
and he wrote a bit of an essay here I'm
going to try to get you guys through it
he wrote let me help you out and give
you my thoughts on Dei number one
diversity good businesses look where
others don't to find the employees that
will put your business in the best
possible position to succeed you may not
agree but I take it as a given that
there are people of various races
ethnicities orientation Etc that are
regularly excluded from hiring
consideration by extending our our
hiring search to include them we can
find people that are more qualified the
loss of Dei phobic companies is my gain
one a we live in a country with very
diverse demographics in this error where
Trust of businesses can be hard to come
by people tend to connect more easily to
people who are like them having a
Workforce that is diverse and
representative of your stakeholders is
good for business two equity treating
people equally does not mean mean
treating them the same I made the
mistake for a lot of years thinking it
did Equity is a core principle of
business put your employees in a
position to succeed recognize their
differences and play to their strengths
wherever possible it is not a hard
concept but it is not easy to implement
most workforces don't have the depth of
management to do this well when it's not
done well it can create tension and
resentment three inclusion one of my
favorite sayings is that great employees
reduce the stress of those around them
great companies create great envir
create environments that reduce
unnecessary stress of their employees
I'm not talking hitting quota or getting
the product out of the door stress which
in turn increases productivity this is
what inclusion is all about making all
employees no matter who they are or how
they see themselves feel comfortable in
their environment and able to do their
jobs again it's not easy or why Dei is
like healthc care one of the lessons
I've learned in healthcare is that most
CEOs don't know and don't really want to
know where their health care benefit
dollars are going in their minds it's
not part of the core competency of their
business as a result they waste a load
of money on less than quality care for
their employees and more often than not
it's their sickest and lowest paid
employees that subsidize the rebates and
deductibles sicker employees have to pay
to their deductible healthy don't so
what does this have to do with Dei like
healthcare Dei is not seen as a core
competency in most companies it's just a
huge expense intellectually they see the
benefit of Dei but they don't have time
to focus on it so it turns into a
checkbox that they hope they don't have
to deal with beyond having HR do a
report to the board and legal tells them
they are covered don't worry I'm almost
there guys when anything that impacts
all of your employees is pretty much a
checklist item to the CEO there is a
good chance that it is not going to work
well and you are going to have employees
who are not comfortable for a lot of
different reasons which in turn creates
resentment towards Dei policies and
training which in turn makes it harder
on the managers trying to implement it
when companies do Dei well you see you
see a well-run successful company so
what's the conclusion if you don't think
there is a need for Dei and it doesn't
create a competitive Advantage for your
company just look at the EXP poost
replies quotes below these are the same
people that work for you or your
co-workers everyone is entitled to their
point of view but these same feelings
even if they are not set up out loud are
heard loud and clear at work okay before
I get into my response Phoenix what did
you call that when someone gives you
just like an essay when you say
something very simple and they give you
a long essay in response what did you
call that college that's the liberal
college girl response right Elon Musk
wrote like one he two tweets there but
like one liners and that is just the
long ass explanation uh I responded to
Mark and I think think I if I dare I say
I whittel it down fairly well to the
problem of what his essay was all about
I said Mark you are defining words in a
way nobody else does and certainly not
how they put them into practice he did
respond he wrote well we disagree there
these are things I do my best to put
into practice my point was that he it's
not that he's not putting what he's
saying into practice the point is that
nobody else is using Dei the way he's
pretending to Define it let's put it
that way anyway after his long di tribe
explaining his version of Dei right we
know it's not we just heard from his own
CEO at his company talking about all the
ways they're using Dei um Elon responded
and I think he nailed it he wrote cool
so when should we expect to see a short
white/ Asian women on the Mavs uh which
is a good point because I don't think
there are any short white or and Andor
Asian women on the Dallas Mavericks Mark
cubin responded to that he said since
this seems to be the most common
response let me address it Dei does not
mean you don't hire on Merit of course
you hire on you hire on Merit diversity
means you expand the possible pool of
candidates as widely as you can once you
have identified the candidates you hire
the best person you believe is the best
what makes the whole what about the
players comment ridiculous is that it
presumes that all positions are hired
based on some quantitative rather than
subjective version of Merit they aren't
even choosing the best basketball player
is very much a guess which is why the
best players weren't always the first
pick in the draft and some go undrafted
the reality is that most positions hired
in a company don't have a quantitative
metric you can use to hire someone how
do you pick the best Barista sales
assistant marketing or salesperson Etc
God there's so much BS here more often
than that it's an educated guest so when
you see a company like IBM say they want
to add x% more people of color or women
or whatever group they already know that
the majority of positions they hire for
don't have metrics for picking best I
don't know how how Mark cubin ever
created a successful company as Elon
Musk said if Merit for a job is roughly
the same then the tiebreaker should be
diversity of all kinds which is exactly
what well-managed companies choose to do
Dei also does not mean you can't fire
someone if you've made a mistake of
course you can I'm a big believer in
hire first a higher slow Fire fast it's
if it's the wrong person fire them
finally let me address the thought that
I'm virtue signaling I wrote this on X
because I knew very well that almost
everyone on here would disagree with me
I don't virtue signal I want people to
challenge my positions I want to have
engaging discussions that help me learn
uh he then uh put out all right so first
off you know I know I'm being a little
snippy let's say with Mark cubin I just
think he he's completely
misunderstanding this but I I will give
credit where credit is due he did post
this on Twitter where he knows most
people are going to disagree with him I
don't really think he's well I can't say
I don't really think he's run his
companies like this because clearly he's
running the Dallas Mavericks like this
with the CEO over there but with all the
tech companies he has I don't know how
many companies he's in charge of or or
has put money towards like I don't think
that they've in the tech companies that
he's created let's say hired people with
any with thinking about diversity Equity
inclusion you you get the best
programmers and of course you do that
when we created locals were we looking
at their race or who they bang on the
side of course not was like could you
code you think I care who these guys
bang on the side I don't care what you
people are doing all day I really don't
as long as you show up for work and you
do a good job and you smile every now
and again and and that's it tell me how
great I am anyway uh then Mark basically
completely blew up his own argument he
tweeted a link to
ESPN and uh it says Cuban would give
Griner a chance with Mavericks Dallas
Mavericks owner mark cubin would be
willing to give Baylor women star
Britney GR gr ER an opportunity to play
on the maps the problem is Britney
grinder would never make the Mavericks
and it's because she's a woman right we
all know that there's a reason that the
WNBA exists it's nice that girls like to
play basketball I went to high school
I'm a little bit older than her but I
went to the same high school as Sue bird
she is thought of as the greatest female
basketball player of all time I played a
couple times with her in the park and
she was pretty damn good but she wasn't
better than most of the guys and she
could have never made it to the NBA so
if you if is it fair to say Britney
grinder is the best female basketball
player right now no who who's the best
terasi Diana terasi but she retired
right like Brianna Stewart Brianna
Stewart look at this guy he
knows God bless you for knowing the
names of several female basketball
players the point is nobody knows their
names and it's it's fine that girls like
basketball I love
basketball and girls can like things
boys can like different it's it's all
good but Mark saying that and posting a
link to it yeah I'd give her a chance
well you'd give her a chance and she
would fail at it she is what do you tell
me
69205 something like that 69 205 so a 69
male basketball player you're usually
about 250 Jack huge you're a power
forward she would be crushed by these
people it's just the truth and we all
know
it